msnbc the tv network not the schedule 3
pharmaceutical
has a birthday today that channel is 25
years old it's hard to believe
especially for those of us who remember
the day it was born
and yet even at this advanced age there
are a lot of misconceptions about msnbc
the first
is that all of its anchors have been
accused by a sitting president of
murdering a young woman in a
congressional office
that's not true it's a myth and we like
to dispel it once and for all right now
the second misperception about msnbc is
that has always been some sort of
left-wing revolutionary channel leon
trotsky tv
and that's not true either from its
first hours msnbc was a purely corporate
project the ms stands for microsoft
the nbc for what was then a division of
general electric
so the channel began as a merger of
business titans and fundamentally it's
still just one big hr department
after the 2004 presidential elections
the geniuses in the programming office
decided to pivot
and make msnbc more populist or
something they weren't sure
exactly what they wanted but they hired
a new prime time anchor
anyway do you wish now
looking back three years that the press
had been a little more vigilant
in asking questions about the invasion
of iraq during the run-up to it like
are we certain there are these wmd
stockpiles that we're using to justify
the war
how do you know that they're there what
exactly are you talking about mr powell
in your speech united nations don't you
wish the press had been a little tough
for the administration
now honestly that's pretty compelling
television but in the end it was not
enough the guy you just saw was fired
for low ratings
he was replaced by an emotionally
stunted agoraphobic baseball card
collector who wore mom jeans to the
office and wrote
florid scripts with too many adjectives
mr keith olbermann ladies and gentlemen
and keep in mind the
l is silent but it was too volatile an
arrangement to last and before long the
network's top star took his mom jeans
and went back to his honus wagner cards
in his sad midtown apartment
but msnbc itself remained and its
evolution continued
like puppies all tv networks are cute
when they're little
the problem is you never know what
they're going to grow up to become
so what is that msnbc now well
effectively it's the hutu radio network
ginning up race fear to mobilize the
militias here's the channel's new lead
anchor screaming once again about those
diabolical white
people and so here we are again
with conservatism at least among a
certain cohort of white guys
now rooting itself in the idea that even
during a pandemic
these screaming men and women have the
god-given right to get their roots done
and
order a steak at the restaurant and hit
the golf course in the bar
and that those rights which they claim
were conferred upon them by
god require a disproportionately black
and brown
labor force to return to work get back
on the wheel and risk
death in order to serve them and return
them to their comfortable lives
broadcasting that crap 24 hours a day
shades of kill golly 94 we regret to
inform you that tomorrow will be killed
with their families
it's pretty ugly but we're gonna rise
above it tonight
and wish the woman you just saw the race
lady along with jeb bush's former flack
the rachel maddow impersonator and most
sincerely rachel maddow herself a very
happy birthday
and we're going to do it with maximum
cultural imperialism
as the irish say on occasions like this
may your life be full of gladness and
health and your pocket full of gold as
the least of your wealth
may the dreams you hold dear be the ones
that come true may all the kindness you
spread keep coming back to you
happy birthday msnbc
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else